Hà Nội Bê cho xe dự phương án và lỗ thủ hình cấp tại gà tổ diện các linh, hà đông.
Trong khoảng 18, đủ đủ thị các linh, hà đông đến tục cập phải một số xe cố nhiều,
nước sò gì trong 8 tạo, mưa dột tại nhà gà và lối kí thuật khiến tạo phản dự khánh chính.
Nếu trục trặc này đã gây xong sau dự lợt, dưới lên lo ngại về chất lượng bận hành của tiến đường rất trên cao đầu tiên tại Hà Nội.
Chúc tình như đó, vào tối người mùa hai thằng sau, Hà Nội Bê cho đã có bộ phương án xử trước hình cấp để đảm bảo ăn tòn và sĩ chỉ hỏi đậu uống định cho tỏa luyên.
Cố thị, phân máy chê tại gà ý nghĩa, hàng bụt bị hương hồng xò anh vùng của bảo xa gì.
Dẫn đến nước người chàn vào khu vụt nhàng gà và bên trong cao đã được lương vị tổ chức 1 xam vực tư và tiến hành xử trước.
máy chê tại khu vực thăng quân và lối đi bộ máy chơi vị thủ.
Bật, cũng đã được tháng sớt, khai thế và bảo giữ.
Mình cảnh đó, lương vị vẫn hành cũng đặc thức hiện việc sử trước và thay mối một số thiết bị kiết thật tại các nhà gà.
Bảo gồm, mang yên giám sát CCTV, loa phát thành, hệ thống dịch dựa tàu và máy bản về tự động.
Gió cần thử ra để làm thủ tục đặt tháng 1, 3 và vẫn chuyển về Việt Nam, việc sử trước sự kiến hoàn thành và tháng 1 năm nay khu trong hai miếng lắm.
Thúc bảo nhiều.